hello my name is archivist Luella and
I'm asking a question from second life
so my question is at the LHC why collide
lead ions and programs instead of some
other element hi archivist Llewellyn I
have a question for you where did you
get that hat you know those are the hat
you're wearing is the Hat my daughter
made for the Nobel week it said gross
the strong force and I didn't know there
were copies available out there and on
ebay or somewhere so where did you get
that about your question why why do they
use lead ions at the LHC they haven't
started using them they will in a few
months colliding lead ions on other lead
ions to make what we hope to see in
greater detail at the LHC than we have
at Brookhaven a hot fire bowl in which
nucleons will melt the form a plasma of
quarks and gluons I don't really know
they might very well use other elements
at Brookhaven they used lead they use
gold they used a bunch of heavy nuclei
you obviously want a very heavy nucleus
that contains many nucleons many many
quarks to form this hot fireball but
gold is just as good as led you probably
choose both gold and lead since they're
stable and easily available elements
that you can ionize easily but there
probably are other practical reasons why
lead is the iron of chores choice at the
LHC